oh dude we gotta clean up your room it's  a complete mess I am good  I'm not coring your coring what's boring  is me tripping over your vines every day  you playing a little video game killing  aliens that's cool how many of you shot  in real life me upwards of several  thousands boring I think not I want to  save the galaxy with a dance-off I'm not  boring Oh  and now I know how y'all knew Phil do  you think  you all a garden of the galaxy guardians  of the galaxy why would we be the  guardians of the galaxy the Ravagers the  sovereign  they want to take over the galaxy so we  saving the galaxy again I guess  [Music]  I see it within you Sarah  betrayal or any of you do with yell at  each other  rad stupid raccoon Starmont you're right  we're family Showtime a whole  [Applause]  [Music]  beautiful  hey what about this little plant can I  smash it with a rock no it's too  adorable to care  you